delia desea construir un intervalo z
para estimar qué proporción de los
miembros de su comunidad están a favor
de un incremento de impuestos que genere
fondos para las escuelas locales ella
requiere un margen de error que no
sobrepase el 2% con un nivel de
confianza del 95% cuál es el tamaño
mínimo de la muestra que se necesita
para obtener el margen de error
requerido bueno recordemos la forma que
tienen los intervalos de confianza y
cuál es la parte correspondiente al
margen de error así que quiere estimar
el valor real de la proporción de la
población que está a favor del
incremento de impuestos supongamos que
son estos de aquí y de hecho este es un
valor que ella desconoce por lo que va a
tomar una muestra de tamaño en y de
hecho el problema en esta ocasión es
determinar esta n
la n que ya necesita para cumplir con el
margen de error requerido y a partir de
esta muestra ella va a calcular una
proporción muestral que va a ser p
sombrero entonces el intervalo que ella
va a construir se va a ver de la
siguiente forma va a ser p sombrero ya
esto le vamos a sumar y restar el valor
crítico de la muestra que en este caso
va a ser z estrella es decir el valor
crítico que corresponden al nivel de
confianza del 95% multiplicado por el
error estadístico que en este caso ese
error va a ser la raíz cuadrada de peso
hombre que va a multiplicar a 1 - p
sombrero ok y esto dividido entre n
y ahora ella quiere que el margen de
error no sea mayor que el 2% es decir
que toda esta parte de aquí no sea mayor
que el 2% por lo tanto va a ser menor o
igual al 2% y como hacemos esto bueno lo
primero es incorporar a la expresión el
95% del nivel de confianza recuerda el
95% del nivel de confianza significa que
si tenemos una distribución normal como
esta que estoy dibujando 95% del nivel
de confianza significa que el número de
desviaciones estándar que requerimos por
arriba y por abajo de la media para
incluir el 95% del área que tenemos aquí
entonces dejamos una cola superior de
2.5 por ciento y lo mismo para la cual
la inferior 2.5 por ciento
buscamos entonces en una tabla zeta no
el 95% sino más bien el porcentaje que
tenga una cola del 2.5 por ciento por lo
que deberás buscar la correspondiente z
al 90 y 7.5 por ciento en general es
importante saber que para un nivel de
confianza del 95 por ciento el valor
crítico correspondiente es
y 1.96 es pueden aprenderse este valor
por supuesto siempre puedes buscarlo en
la tabla zeta pero aquí ya sabemos que
esto nos dará 1.96 y por lo tanto este
valor crítico es 1.96 ahora que hay con
p sombrero bueno no conocemos cuánto
vale sombrero pues aún no se ha tomado
la muestra y al final de cuentas la
pregunta es qué tan grande debe ser la
muestra que tomemos hemos dicho que
queremos que esto sea menor o igual al
2% todo esto que tengo aquí lo que
podemos hacer es elegir una proporción
muestral ojo no sabemos cuál es el
verdadero valor que vamos a obtener pero
podemos elegir el valor que maximicen
esta parte de acá dentro pues si
maximizamos esto sabemos que estaremos
básicamente obteniendo el valor máximo
de todo este radical por lo que
estaremos seguros así que para obtener
el valor máximo de
este sombrero es decir la p que maximice
este producto bueno podemos aplicar
prueba y error no es tan complicado pero
podemos observar también que esta es una
expresión cuadrática y de aquí vamos a
obtener un valor para p para p sombrero
de 0.5 quiere insistir en que
desconocemos ape sombrero porque de él
ya aún no ha tomado la muestra aleatoria
para calcular la proporción muestral
recuerda queremos el valor de n así que
para asegurar se va a considerar cuál es
la proporción muestral que proporciona
un valor máximo del margen de error
entonces va a suponer este valor para
intentar calcular n así que de una vez
voy a establecer la desigualdad por aquí
tengo 1.96 que es el valor crítico x
la raíz cuadrada de vamos a suponer 0.5
como la proporción muestral aunque
desconocemos aún su valor hasta que no
tomemos la muestra pero lo voy a poner
0.5 que multiplica a 1 menos 0.5 lo cual
es 0.5 de nuevo ok y esto a su vez está
dividido entre n
y todo esto va a ser menor o igual al 2%
no queremos que este margen de error sea
mayor que el 2% así que esto lo voy a
poner como un 0.02 el 2% y ahora sólo
necesitamos hacer un poco de álgebra
para obtener este valor de n esto lo
podemos escribir como bueno qué te
parece si primero multiplico de ambos
lados por uno entre 1.96 para cancelar
este de aquí y del otro lado voy a hacer
lo mismo y ahora tenemos que de este
lado izquierdo este con este se van y me
queda simplemente la raíz cuadrada de m
bueno aquí tengo 0.5 por 0.5 ya eso le
voy a sacar la raíz cuadrada por el cual
solamente me quedan 0.5 y esto dividido
entre la raíz cuadrada de nm déjame
ponerlo y esto va a ser menos
o igual que y ahora tengo 0.02 bueno eso
lo puedo escribir como 2 sobre 100 ok
esto que a su vez está dividido entre
1.96 bueno esto es lo mismo que 2 entre
196 ahora si tomamos el recíproco de
ambos lados voy a obtener bueno el
recíproco de esto va a ser la raíz
cuadrada de n entre 0.5 y del otro lado
voy a obtener 196 entre 2 cuantos 196
entre 2
eso es 98 entonces voy a poner 98 y como
estoy tomando los recíprocos entonces la
desigualdad se voltea esto va a ser
mayor o igual que 98 y ahora voy a
multiplicar de ambos lados por 0.5 por
0.5 de lado
y por 0.5 del lado derecho de tal manera
que este y éste se cancelan y me queda
simplemente la raíz cuadrada de n esto
tiene que ser mayor o igual que 98 por
0.5
eso es 49 ok eso quiere decir que n
tiene que ser mayor o igual que 49
elevado al cuadrado y esto cuánto es
bueno sabemos que se encuentra el
cuadrado es 2500 y va a estar cerca de
ese valor así que viendo los incisos
podemos darnos cuenta de que la
respuesta es el inciso d pero vamos a
calcular cuánto es 49 por 49 veamos
9 por 9 81 llevamos 8 9 por 4 es 36 y 8
son 44
y después 4 por 9 36 y llevamos 3 y 4
por 4 16 y 3 es 10 y 9 y si ahora
sumamos esto me va a quedar 110 llevamos
una 14 y llevábamos unam y 22 mil 401
que es justo el inciso d así que de lujo
ya tenemos la respuesta éste es el
tamaño mínimo de la muestra que deberá
tomar d elia si requiere que su margen
de error sea menor que el 2%
ahora puede resultar que su margen de
error al tomar una muestra de 2.401 si
la proporción de la muestra es menor que
0.5 o mayor que 0.5 pudiera ser entonces
que su margen de error sea menor que el
2% pero este es el valor que no
queríamos rebasar otro punto a tomar en
cuenta es que en este caso resultó que
el valor de n es un número entero pero
si hubiéramos obtenido por ejemplo
2400 1.5 necesitaríamos redondear
entonces al siguiente entero ya que el
tamaño de la muestra siempre va a ser un
número entero bien aquí lo dejamos así
que nos vemos en el próximo vídeo